good morning John it's Friday you're an
author you love books I love books too I
read a lot of no apparently I'm mildly
dyslexic enough that I read it the level
of a third grader cárdenas staples Tesla
listen we would making books for
thousands of years now so you'd think
that we'd have perfected the process and
yet I have some things that I would like
to discuss with publishing companies so
I love to spend time in bookstores and
to figure out what I want I read the
reviews and I read the blurbs and also I
read the description why would you put a
major spoiler in the description on the
back of the book I don't want to be
halfway through a book and the thing
that I know is gonna happen hasn't
happened yet cuz I read it on the thick
that's like two paragraph is it so hard
to keep us foiler out of that why would
you do that interestingly Looking for
Alaska does not do this but in one
edition that I noticed so there's the
author bio on the back page and it's
like Putin for Alaska was written by
John Breen who liked to make candy canes
not a pops and lives with his puppy in
Indianapolis so it says right if you
turn to that page to read about the
author which you might want to do before
you read the book on the facing page
there's a like a question for you know
reader questions for like if it's hot in
a school or something
and the question is do you think that
spoiler spoiler was a spoiler or a
spoiler think about this stop okay also
the book is part of the series please
just let me know on the cover or the
inside flap just like five words this is
the second book in the sword of butts
trilogy so I know doing like graphic
novels do it just put a little number on
the bottom that it's uh it's great
there's nothing wrong with except when
you do this never ever that's the worst
thing on my bookshelf they're all first
editions that's not even from a
different edition this made a mistake
and I hate it so much
anyway covers you can't judge a book by
them but don't if it's like a really
high quality fantasy epic I don't want
to see a half naked guy on a horse with
a sword I'm not gonna believe that it's
a good book if there's a half-naked guy
on a sword with a horse on a sword with
a horse I take it back if there's a
happy guy on a sword then I'll probably
bite Apple the capitated why a fiction
ladies stop we've had enough books that
look like they're Twilight put on
Twilight no why would you do that okay
here's another thing
this is the the ocean at the end of the
lane amazing but this I don't know if
you can see this but get let's get in
here this is your deckled edge where
it's not it's not flat why why why this
makes it harder to read the book and
it's always in books that are like
fancier and more expensive so it must
cost more if you're paying more for
something that makes something less
functional maybe not new it's like
during those years when pants got really
expensive if they pad pre-made holes in
them I can make my own pant holes thank
you also just don't lie to me is the
Casual Vacancy by JK Rowling and it says
in the back the big novel about a small
town that became a number one worldwide
bestseller that is a little misleading
it overcame insurmountable odds to
become this popular book is written by
the 11th most popular author of all time
it might become a number one bestseller
I don't think anybody was surprised
books are nice but they're not a perfect
format I mean you have to charge the
battery all the time there's all those
annoying pop-up advertisements pre-rolls
what I'm basically saying is this is a
far superior media to most of them
except for vlogbrothers videos which are
the best of all the media
I'm pinnacle in it this is the Cadillac
of the ultimate dot penultimate which
does not mean the same thing which I
learned while I was giving an oral
presentation and somebody laughed at me
so John I'll see you on Tuesday the
first episode of the art assignment is
online right now go to youtube.com slash
the art assignment and watch it too Yeti
has a YouTube channel who woulda guessed